[Música]
revista al prensa en directo américa de
francia 24 me acompaña en el estudio
rosa pérez más de burros a bienvenida ya
comenzamos una semana más de información
aquí en directo américa de france 24 y
vamos a dedicar la revista de prensa el
día de oberá figura del pensador ruso
alexander dogging quien supuestamente
era un objetivo de un ataque con un
carro bomba que mató a su hija este
sábado veamos entonces el rosa como lo
enfoca en distintos medios de
comunicación
empezando por el ruso sputnik que titula
quién es el padre de daria doguín ha
escrito por oxy descrito por occidente
como el ideólogo jefe de putin buenos
días raúl exactamente no dice sputnik
que tras el homicidio de su hija daria
divina como decías los medios
occidentales no han tardado en describir
a su padre alexander dogging como aliado
ayudante cercano o cerebro de la
geoestrategia de putin dice sin embargo
the street describirlo como pensador
político con estrechos lazos con el
kremlin o incluso con putin
personalmente es impreciso en el mejor
de los casos o una afirmación de
tabloide en él entonces como lo escribes
putin rosa bien se remonta a su salto a
la esfera pública se dio a conocer a
edwin por su oposición abierta a la
perestroika y podrá fundar el partido
nacional bolchevique en 1993 una
formación que sputnik dice que tenía un
objetivo que era fusionar lo
aparentemente irreconciliables el
ultranacionalismo y el comunismo bien en
1998 por descrito discrepancias internas
doguín abandonó el partido bolchevique
nacional y se convirtió en un prominente
defensor del euro sionismo una ideología
que sputnik defiende define de la
siguiente manera una ideología ecléctica
que consiste en el nacionalismo fe
ortodoxa ideas socialistas anti
progresismos antiprogresistas misticismo
oposición al social liberalismo y al
capitalismo estadounidense ross a
discrepancias o similitudes que le
atribuyen al pensamiento de vladimir
putin bien dicen por un lado putin no es
socialista sus políticas están basadas
en principios del libre mercado por otro
lado dice a diferencia de putting doing
tiene a la unión soviética en un
pedestal por otro lado dice putin no
tiene una visión euroasiática sino que
siempre ha querido
normalizar las relaciones con la unión
europea dicen además during ha
expresado- abiertas discrepancias con el
kremlin en 2014 por ejemplo criticó al
kremlin por no tener una línea más dura
respecto a la crisis en el donbass tal y
como lo llama sputnik dice en 2019
elogió a putin por salvar a rusia pero
dijo que ninguno de sus éxitos son
irreversibles también se remontan a una
entrevista de 2015 en la que edwin dijo
que no conocía a putin personalmente y
que el mandatario nunca le había
respondido a las cartas que le había
enviado sin embargo no sabemos si a día
de hoy siete años más tarde si se
conocen o no cambiamos de medio rosa
vamos al salto que le hizo un perfil en
el mes de marzo exactamente este perfil
está escrito por la filósofa montserrat
galcerán ella dice que duggan era bueno
basa su pensamiento en el de la filósofo
alemán y heidegger y equipara a du coeur
con steve banon recordemos quien fue
asesor del expresidente de eeuu donald
trump dijo quedó bien en recuerda
dirigió sag art tv que compara con el
fox news de eeuu por otro lado dice en
2013 se publicó en español en las
ediciones nueva república de filiación
neofascista uno de sus últimos libros
una mezcla de crítica del liberalismo
del posmodernismo del marxismo y sólo en
parte del fascismo clásico que más nos
dice la autora rosa el pensamiento de
dublín basado en los pensadores nazis
dice durán reformula con heidegger la
vieja pregunta kantiana que es el hombre
transformada en quiénes somos nosotros
dice heidegger respondía somos alemanes
atrapados en el auge del liberalismo del
oeste y del bolchevismo en el este y
necesitamos luchar por nuestro propio
espacio vital doing dice por el
contrario somos rusos que frente al auge
del liberalismo global necesitamos
reforzar el espacio de nuestra
civilización una pretendida esfera
euroasiática no y esta esfera euro
digamos la defiende de la siguiente
manera
digamos que establece una limitación que
pasa por el medio de ucrania dice la
frontera occidental de la civilización
euroasiática va un poco más al este de
la frontera occidental de ucrania por lo
que el estado recientemente establecido
es inviable y frágil y la autora termina
este artículo diciendo si el mensaje de
trampa era make américa great again el
mensaje de during me temo que es el
mismo pero en su traducción al ruso como
describe a dublín rose a al yazira bien
al jazeera dice que hay que reconocer
que during es una voz influyente sobre
la visión que tiene putin del mundo pero
que hay que dudar sobre cuál es el
alcance digamos de esta influencia no y
dice mientras algunos lo llaman el
rasputín actual no digamos otros señalan
que se exagera su influencia sobre él
créeme además al yazira también arroja
ciertas dudas sobre el objetivo del
ataque no porque si bien se ha
especulado mucho que el objetivo real
del ataque era alexander dogging y no su
hija al yazira dice que ella se estaba
convirtiendo cada vez más una figura
prominente y que por lo tanto podría
haberse ido ella directamente el
objetivo de este atentado y cerramos
rápidamente con the times exactamente
times este medio británico sí que pues
como decíamos se titula a tilda a during
the ultranacionalista pro invasión ante
ucrania alguien que digamos a nadie pone
en duda pero digamos que nos da algunos
detalles sobre este atentado y es que si
bien al yazira decía que se puede dudar
sobre si su hija fue realmente el
objetivo principal o no digamos que the
times señala en su portada de hoy que
duggan le prestó las llaves de su carro
a su hija en el último momento no por lo
tanto que digamos él supuestamente era
quien debía conducir este coche que
finalmente explotó con una bomba en su
interior gracias.rosa por toda la
información mañana con más de revista de
prensa pasamos a saludar a nuestro
primer invitado al día